[Laughter]
you're listening to the dollop on the
all things comedy Network now this is a
buy American history podcast each week
solid emission I crank yankor mower of
lawns hairy face guy Dave Anthony reads
a story from American history to his
friend Gareth Reynolds who has no idea
what the topic is going to be about
funny gonna do something interesting
tell it intro do some recalibrating from
crank yanking your this is jam-packed
chant and I'm the [ __ ] hippo guy Dave
okay Gary but it's good and this is not
gonna come particularly
sick arguments
[Music]
what's your name Garrett Gareth yeah
Jonnie upcoming I'll be at the Moontower
Comedy Festival in Austin April 25th
through the 27th and until then I'll be
maxing
don't say that ever again to anybody or
me no life there's nobody you should say
that to the dhaba money
tour we're we got a show coming up on
March 16th in Durham North Carolina the
Carolina theorem if you want to avoid
Ticketmaster call the theater directly
Columbus Ohio at the Davidson theater on
a March 30th and then we'll be in
Brooklyn on May 18th that show the
there's four show sold out so we had a
second show at 10:30 p.m. hmm
PMS in the peas I'm 30 and the peas and
pretty soon we'll have some special
announcements coming up won't way about
live shows we are brought to you by
square space which is a space that is
square yeah
Squarespace is of course as you guys
know it is a website huge in Garrick or
huge and gear core we're big fans
obviously because we have your website
yeah my personal website and what
stand-ups your stand-ups and then we do
our we do our our sources yeah we use
age yeah we use it you're so angry just
we use it we get it
look Squarespace is awesome I use it
because I like the templates they look
very clean and nice and they're easy to
set up because I'm an idiot when it
comes to stuff like this yeah two of us
you don't know much you can showcase
your work give me blogs you can sell
products you can promote your physical
online business which there's a way to
promote my physical on I'm sorry a
physical or online business
they got ecommerce functionality they
got 24/7 award-winning customer support
free and secure hosting built in search
engine optimized tons it's every
thing yeah it's everything yes so get on
some Squarespace is what I'm saying
right yeah I don't think that's what
they would like you how they would like
you to pay what's there that's actually
their slogan go squares no no way
so check out Squarespace calm for a free
trial when you're ready to launch use
the offer code dollop to save 10% off
your first purchase of a website or
website hey Aaron let's roll back take
another one see the blooper reel 10% off
your first purchase of a website idiot
that's squarespace.com on a web soup
that's squarespace.com enter code dollop
man you're not helpful I'm trying so
hard I just want people to like me oh
man
we are also sponsored by untuck it dude
they are great shirts oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah I yeah go ahead with the ad but I
was I'm into him you're wearing them
yeah one this week in Nashville where
they don't recycle everyone why
traditional button-up stick so long look
so long and baggy
that's because they were never meant to
be worn that way untucked shirts were
specifically designed to be worn
untucked untuck it is the brand you've
been looking for it's the original
untucked shirt a modern solution to an
old problem with no tucking your
tailoring required no matter your size
or shape the shirts are the perfect
untucked length I I was gonna say I love
them well that's not awesome yeah
they're great yeah I mean yeah I didn't
know it was like a thing I didn't know I
needed help that's right I was like oh
you're not supposed to walk around like
like it's a nightie like you're sleeping
over it like a pitchers house that
you're wearing is Jersey that's not a
shirts are supposed to look yeah so
they're great they have more than 50 fit
combinations they look great on tall
short slim athletic guys of all ages I'm
the more roundish leduc but it looks
good it's a shirt you know I have a
problem with shirts because of the
boobies
oh man good lad
so they look good that's uh targets so
try try it on in person at one of untuk
it's 50 stores or go to I'm Tucket calm
to get started they offer free shipping
and returns on all orders in the US you
can save 20% off on your first order by
using our code dollop at checkout
that's untuck it calm promo code dollop
mm-hmm and we are also sponsored by
ritual which of course is a vitamin
situation yeah for ladies yeah you can
still take it though Garrett I happened
right no look we all want to do the
right thing to keep our bodies healthy
in the long way well most of us yeah I
don't wanna I'm eating a lot of ice
cream even if we try really hard to eat
kale salads and drink green smoothies
were still most likely not getting all
the essential nutrients we need on a
daily basis enter ritual the obsessively
researched vitamin for women rituals
essentials have the nutrients most of us
don't get enough of from food all in
their clean absorbable forms no shady
additives or ingredients they can be
more harm to your body than good take
too easy to take capsules they provide 9
nutrients you need to support a strong
foundation for your health like you said
I've said this before me and my wife
we're trying to make a another human and
we were doing it with the sex stuff and
then you know you want to keep your body
clean at that point you know I'm talking
about dairy and and so but she was being
put on vitamins but you don't know
what's in them right so it could be
anything because they don't keep track
of that but ritual totally transparent
they tell you everything that's in the
vitamins surprisingly that's the thing
that matters I know it's right it should
be a thing that you should know but but
they literally Congress like that
doesn't matter what you look it's a
little grainy it's a little plastic
thing bull made it so so for obsessive
label readers all rituals vegan friendly
sugar-free non-gmo gluten-free and
allergen free ingredients and their
sources are out there for everybody to
see
it's a subscription-based service it's
easy to snooze if you want it's only a
dollar today to have all the essential
nutrients your body needs deliver tea
every month no strings attached so
better health doesn't happen overnight
help fill the gaps with your diet with
essential for women a small step that
helps support a healthy foundation for
your body visit ritual calm slash dollop
to start your ritual today that's ritual
calm slash dollop mm-hmm
and of course we are sponsored by hello
fresh hello fresh is a food delivery
service which we now use everything that
comes in their bags is recyclable not
natural though in Nashville you can just
throw it on the street you got some
issues with Nashville what it's just you
know how about a recycling bin I get it
hello fresh makes conquering the kitchen
a reality with deliciously simple
recipes cooking is enjoyable and easy
with hello fresh fresh pre-measured
ingredients and easy-to-follow six-step
pictured recipe cards are delivered to
your door each week in a special
insulated box and great vegetarian
options i should say all meals yes all
meals come together in 30 minutes max
call for less than two pots and pans and
require minimal cleanup yeah get out of
that recipe right and start cooking
outside of your comfort zone by
discovering new delicious recipes oh we
made the way you didn't but my wife made
a little pork situation tonight as that
and you infer with some simulating the
sweet potatoes and and then also that
was great and then before that we made a
chicken parmesan
I had a small about it but it was yeah
yeah so anyway we really like it it
tastes really good better than other
places for $80 off that's $20 off your
first four boxes go to hell of fresh
calm slash dollop eighty interesting and
enter promo code dollop 80 that's hello
fresh calm slash dollop eighty and enter
promo code dollop 84 $20 off your first
four boxes I just got confused cuz
there's little brackets sure that's
tough yeah I don't like brackets yeah
why are you bracketing me sure we should
point out that we are recording this at
the all things comedy studio and that
and they have an all things comedy
YouTube page where you can watch any of
the video uploads
of this and you can also check out the
work of an all things comedy brother who
we lost recently named Steven Brody
Stevens who is someone if you're not
familiar with is worth checking out his
stand-up and his show that was on all
things comedy or his other show I think
it was enjoy it
but he was a very unique comedian yeah
someone who everybody in the comedy
world he was beloved by everybody who's
I think if he could see the outpouring
of affection that he has caused he would
probably be surprised I'm like all of us
yeah okay that was a tough one yeah it
was it's been a tough year yep
agreed February 12th 18 you fine you can
smooch doubt it bro come on go come on
February 12th 1884 right we're back not
really 1884 1884 okay here of our Lord
yeah the 80s track time they even said
it like that like it's the 80s look rip
your teeth out it's the 80s that's not
no one ripped their teeth that oh you
start the story Alice Lee Roosevelt was
born her father was Theodore Roosevelt
jr. known as Teddy okay Teddy went to
Harvard where he met Alice Hathaway
Leigh in 1878
she was a Boston Banking Harris Harris
they were introduced by a classmate of
her cousin Richard a middle [ __ ] dick
salt still okay Dave but that is the
best one that's like I've won it I
wasn't good what is it he has nothing to
do with the story but the name is
everything to do with this story he's
the main character of the story
Richard middlecoff so first of all
Richard his dick so dick middle [ __ ] and
that will they call him dick so Richard
middle [ __ ] dick salt stole salts so
he's that sounds like what happens to
your penis in a deprivation tank I just
put his name in there because this is
how rich people name their kids it's a
good it's not a good system it's a great
system bad system yeah
so uh Teddy and Alice married two years
later said he went to Columbia Law
School
they're all up in the New York society
world Teddy ran because obviously
Teddy's a Roosevelt so when Teddy ran
for New York State Assembly and he won
he's big on taking down corruption
that's his jam Allison Teddy bought a
large home and plan to have a large
family okay it's all it's all great yeah
for sure it's all great ya know so Alice
Lea Roosevelt Longworth was born at home
on West 57th Street okay regular
apartment birth yeah it's just what you
did back then yeah yep water birth two
days later Teddy was in Albany when he
received a telegram his mother's health
was fading okay she was in the house
that the baby's born and I don't know if
she lived there or she was just staying
there but she was there in the house
okay
wait so he receives message that so he's
his mother who's in the house yeah okay
baby and his mom
so Teddy rushes home he doesn't rush
home for the baby I'm not sure if he
knew his baby's being born but he's like
let that happen and like your mom's sick
he's like I gotta go I gotta go I mean
who knows back then what it was like but
I would imagine that he was there for
the birth and then he went back to
Albany and then he got this call yeah we
have a 4:30 you gotta hit it yeah you
gotta hit it 4:30 yeah so he rushes home
and his brother Elliott opens up the
door when he gets there and Elliott said
quote there is a curse on this house
Elliott that's bad that's a bad a dark
opener if you if yeah that's the first
thing someone says to you then how about
a hello yeah there's a dude curse on
this house you're a bummer
we have ghosts say hello hello we're
dying in here now cuz there's a curse
you're not dying you're just saying [ __ ]
come on in
hey take off your shoes please okay my
shoes are off yeah there's a curse upon
you [ __ ] I'm a devil uh turns out
Teddy's mother she's burning up with a
fever she has typhoid okay that's not
good
meanwhile
stairs Alice he goes up to see her she
barely recognizes Teddy because she had
an undiagnosed case of Bright's disease
which is kidney a kidney disease okay so
she been living with it for a while but
the pregnancy made it worse so it like
kicked in and it's acute now Teddy's
mother died at 3:00 a.m. and Alice died
11 hours later oh my god
bambam Wow yeah okay I think I'm
starting to see Elliot's side of this a
little yeah that's sure yeah the point
kind of a curse time now you're like
Elliott how did you know and then you're
walking around like shut that baby up
yeah who will uh uh Teddy Teddy was just
25 years old Wow and he lost his mama
and wife on the same day so he is
insanely in love with his wife he had
fill pages of his diary about how much
he'd order which a little much yeah take
it easy no you we get it you think
someone's gonna do because that's the
thing in five years she's gonna be like
you know used to always write in your
diary about me yeah I still love you I
you know the house is cursed one reason
I know this is you're dead it's on this
day he just wrote a large black X in the
diary so if you're seeing that you're
sort of like let's head he's not doing
great
and the only thing you wrote was the
light has gone out of my life okay sure
and then I assumed he drew like a little
light bulb and then a slash through it
yeah and then okay there bud Teddy would
never speak his wife's name again so he
was he didn't need therapy
anything he was fine no now this is also
weird that he didn't speak his wife's
name again because they named their
daughter Alice now is there now what is
that hard to make is it time for a name
change rather than just oh no motion of
wait that was an idea you had yeah
change the name yeah yeah they didn't do
that no so just like you
well we're locked in you you you
Oh baby baby lady baby lady baby little
baby lady so obviously that's weird
yeah not only did he not speak her name
again
but he would not allow anyone else in
his presence to speak his wife's name it
taking on a real sort of Scientology
vibe now where it's not great no Jenny
told a friend the way to survive was to
keep the pain buried as deep inside as
literally is saying what now we use as
like the stereotype for things you're
not supposed to do you know the key is
to bury it deep inside yourself and wait
for an occasion when you could explode
and then go to Africa and kill animals
take it out on Tigers right so keep the
pain buried as deep inside as possible
or it will destroy you that is actually
that's right that's the way to grieve
obviously this is not a widely held
psychological belief today
anyway that's how a little Alice Lee
came into the world she would be called
baby Lee cool double funeral was held
and Alice Lee was crit christening the
day after oh geez
so they didn't they could have switched
the [ __ ] name up yeah yes baby Lee
it's like baby dryer which was good baby
driver yeah at the end of 1884 Teddy
decided just to get out of politics
obviously he's got a rough well what's
going on so he bails he had bought two
ranches in North Dakota after he'd gone
there previously to hunt Buffalo so in
his grief he made for the ranches which
are in the isolated Badlands of North
Dakota and he leaves baby Lee behind
also known as Alice so what's the plan
well he has a sister sure that is taking
care of her okay so he's just living in
this is North Dakota North Dakota Teddy
is a badass okay he is he's out there
hunting buffalos okay and
other animals there is yeah it looks
like a man is dealt with his inside
demons he gets a job as sheriff okay um
he's lays a rest in thieves he's going
on month-long roundups like he's just a
totally different on anything but the
death of his wife and mother basically
he beat up a gunfighter to slim how dare
you just take that Alice and that Alice
you left me Alice my name's Jim shut up
Ellis why did you go away bro bro bro
hey okay hey my name is Jeff right here
this alone no we shouldn't
no we're not going to give in okay all
right just once missed you
did you finish your inside oh good to
see you babe yeah great president thank
you well but if I ever get over this
we're gonna live so happy together here
Alice my name's Jeff Alice and us
my wife's alive again and I'm inside of
her again and we're together and you are
for sure Alice I'm Jeff
so Teddy's becoming the badass that
everyone knows Trey Rosa this is the
origin story yeah basically he still
cared for Alice in one 1884 letter he
wrote quote I hope mousey kins will be
very cunning
I shall dearly love her whoa dude
honestly I mean baby Leigh was tough
changed the name changed the name mousey
Kelly yeah that's weird it's [ __ ]
I wouldn't you would never expect that
to come out of Ted where's mousey kid
where is I want to shoot mousy kids this
is the man who kills ends religiously
yeah Mao sickens so Alice is being
raised by Teddy's sister Anna
in New York and I was also known as by
which is the nickname she got because
she was always on the move it was short
for hi anna by anna nicknames really
they're good yes family they're not good
so Alice called her aunty Bai okay aunty
bye
she's very strong intelligent
independent woman with a huge influence
on Alice and she also had a hump
she had a hump mm like the one on the
back like the Quasimodo okay so she has
a hump sure she's your classic hump to
Roosevelt sure she's just names by
continued Dave this she's in her late
20s and not married which could have
something to do with the hump oh come on
you got to get on hump me she took very
are you missing other people with humps
in your area it's like farmers meter
farmersonly.com hump me it was great so
but she took very good care of Alice
sure Teddy would sometimes make brief
visits when he came back for work when
he did he would spend time with baby Lea
evening mouths Eakins or Alice whatever
her name now second yes mouseykin thank
you in June 1886 Teddy returned so I
guess he's over his grief now comes back
to New York
I think he's not it's not that he's over
it he's just buried it deep yeah that
now I could never yeah you need a
treasure map to get to the demons he
said he finishes building a house he'd
started before his wife died it becomes
Alice's full-time dad again okay
so Teddy has previously had a
relationship with a woman named so
that's our our little girl so that's
messy Kenz that's messy can I love it
he said he previously had a relationship
with a woman in Edith Carow they grew up
next door to each other
the everyone thought they're gonna get
married he did ask her to marry and
twice but Teddy's father and aeleus
grandfather were against the marriage
because of potential physical
disabilities they both thought the other
family had I think that has something to
do with the hump Oh
so the grandpa was like we ain't having
hub kids that's right I think that's
exactly what happen hump chin and who
knows what was happening on either side
of the family yeah so Teddy the hump
gene skips a generation and I thought oh
my god if your grandpa had a hump then
you won't have one no then you have a
hump but your dad won't have a hump all
right mm-hmm
I like I like talking to people that are
not you well anyway
Teddy come back so Teddy and went on to
marry Alice and then obviously that
didn't work out so now he rekindled his
relationship with Edith okay okay yeah
so he's back in the picture okay all
right
it starts just looks like a nightmare to
be me to dress like a woman back then is
a nightmare
oh yeah it goes like she's got a collar
on yeah it goes all the way up to the
top it's like just look sick all right
well let me put on my sleeping-bag dress
and go out for the day it's just like
you were forced to wear a Snuggie all
the time so tonight they're hot they get
hot and heavy quick he proposes she says
yes where's grandpa he's passed on I
guess yeah I guess that's all over now
so they get married at the end of 1886
so Alice's life is always about to
change again massacres massacres so
Edith and Teddy moved to Oyster Bay Long
Island Alice or baby Lee moved in with
them Edith apparently had a problem with
the fact that Teddy had a child with
someone else and now the kid was living
with them is this not the sort of stuff
that you maybe talk about in the
courting process well no I don't I think
that Marissa just like you have an
unveiling where you're like I have a
daughter I think he doesn't care
he doesn't care what I think he doesn't
care that she's upset about Alice okay
and and also the first Alice his wife
was super hot okay and I think that
also so what she feels like she's in the
shadows a little bit jealousy going on
sure mmm so I mean in Teddy's just like
well if you feel bad just bury your
feelings deep down into your organ deep
so they start cranking out babies teddy
need if they would end up having five
kids so what do they call Alice because
she's no longer a baby right and there's
five other kids there uh-huh
kiddies oh so they picked a great name
to call her mm-hmm
sister hmm okay sister sure sure so
right now she's just an extra in her own
life remarkably generic yeah how'd they
come up with that is that a family name
by the way that's that's a sister that's
the first mom oh that's a Gao so yes so
they call her sister which is I can't
think of what like how about a [ __ ]
nickname of some kind
yeah but a name what about Li like
that's her yeah sister is the most
generic horrible you're not here well
you would also that's like something
that you would like you'd hear back then
people be like sister and she turned on
the gas like no my actual sister what's
your name sister yes
so this created a feeling of shame that
was related to her name and probably
wasn't great for building self-esteem
cool Edith didn't hide her feelings
about Alice's dead mother
Edith called Alice an insipid childlike
fool in front of her daughter cool once
during a fight Eve told Alice that if
her mother had lived she would have
bored teddy to death
she'll wear chill pills invented yet eat
is a [ __ ] monster
rude yeah super super rude as Alice grew
up became clear she was going to be very
attractive like her mom okay this
probably didn't help the situation with
Edith and the tension built between this
is this is a story of Cinderella yeah
okay
Edith was a strict Episcopalian with a
quote cold and detached insistence on
standards of conduct
so she was Episcopalian she insisted
Alice call her mother but Alice would
later write quote she had almost a gift
for making her own people uncomfortable
Alice had a gift for making evil Edith
had a comfortable but she was forcing
Alice to call her mother well yeah she's
sister it's like well yeah look we're in
a play where we haven't named the
characters yet teddy was also pretty
emotionally distant from Alice possibly
because her name was Alice sure and he
was usually absent working on his
political career he would write letters
to the kids and in them he discussed the
other children like he wrote a letter to
one kid and talk about all the other
kids but he'd never mentioned Alice
except when he wrote letters to Ted jr.
it was the only one he talked about
Alice with okay at one point Allison
Teddy had a fight about never speaking
her mother's name which was obviously
her name too so so she was you know
aware of it yeah she's like this is
weird
yeah this is [ __ ] it's much talking
about my mom yeah and my name Alice was
also surprised to learn learned that
Edith was quote not Papa's sister did
Edith was not Papa's sister yeah wait
I'm Alice was surprised to learn that
Edith was not Papa's sister she's pretty
young at that point I would assume so so
she is when they were married she
thought that Teddy and Edith were
brother and sister and having five
children yeah maybe she didn't know how
stuff work but again also a lot of
cousins married back then and simpler
time a simpler time when you could just
go to a family luncheon and meet your
soul mate you know no one was off-limits
it made it a lot easier when you grew up
with your wife that's right back to
simpler times man trumpet Alice felt
that Teddy saw her has as a quote guilty
burden okay what did that come from did
she have senses
[Laughter]
and this just reinforced the decision to
never speak the name Alice even once
Teddy never realized this was creating
resentment and Alice
well well clearly he's very
psychologically minded yes clearly he's
a man who knows how to get into the
emotions that's right yeah so this
mixture orphaned child who felt
responsible for her mother's death given
the same name that was never spoken
angry about being left by a father
create a rebellious child all right you
can imagine yeah in her journal in 1903
she wrote quote father doesn't care for
me that is to say 1/8 as much as he does
for the other children we are not in the
least congenial and if I don't care over
much for him and don't take interest in
the things he likes why should he pay
any attention to me or the things that I
live for except to look on them with
disapproval so things are good okay how
old is she there she's so she's born in
84 so oh three so she's you know she's a
teen 19 right yeah I might have jumped
on that one so so Alice had to learn
about her mother from relatives so
because he never talked about it he
didn't exist the only people she would
occasionally go visit her mom's parents
and they would tell her we'd love to
talk about Alice we don't talk about her
either
Julie yeah granddaughter and to top it
off Alice thought Teddy loved the four
children he had with Edith more Alice
also wore braces a child which she
called quote a medieval instrument of
torture we're trying to help yeah I
can't believe they had braces then hmm
not not yeah it's like one of the yeah
well like a back brace or some kind of
brace like that yeah oh she had hunch
prevention she might
I get it I get you HP HP HP cuz imagine
braces then you've got yet
Alice would later describe herself
during these years as quote stodgy too
shy rather chunky and not a little
cowardly a shy uncomfortable child not
very bright and lethargic okay she's
describing herself like okay so she's
sure self diagnosis so she's a very
unhappy child and that meant she spent
time fantasizing hmm quote I would spend
hours of time pretending I was able to
it will to turn into something quite
different such as a princess with very
long hair or an extremely Marshall
Prince Teddy joined up to fight in the
war against Spain which made him that
made him famous right after he became
governor of New York
Alice was now in her teens and I become
very independent and outgoing okay Edith
couldn't handle her so they decided to
send her to a school for girls in New
York City Alice was not down
quote I had seen miss Spencer Scholars
marching two by two in their daily walks
and thought of becoming one shriveled me
fare so that's that's a good use of
words yeah number one yeah and that's
against it uh-huh
anti she wrote Teddy quote if you send
me I will humiliate you I will do
something that will shame you I tell you
I will that's you read that letter from
your daughter okay I just said how are
things boarding school our things if you
do this I will crush you father what why
I
head on my wall daddy zhenia boarding
schools off at that point sure he was
like that's a good I get you're okay no
Edith was not impressed with Alice
riding a friend that she quote cares
neither for athletics nor good works
okay and she had quote the habit of
running the streets uncontrolled with
every boy in town okay all right
she also said Alice does not do anything
unless she was made to so Alice was sent
back to live with her aunt
Otto or aunt by right and by with the
hello by humph huh auntie humph and a
hump bye and a hunt bye so this time in
America a woman's goal was marriage sure
I mean not probably not woman's go but
the society skull for the floor women I
would imagine not all women are like my
goal is get married no they were like my
goal is to not be beaten so I'll do what
you people say so for that to happen her
behavior needed to be beyond reproach
reproach right to get right but because
of the way Alice had been raised Alice
felt she could never trust a man to love
her so she acted like a woman whose goal
was not to get married Hey she was
impetuous stubborn and insensitive this
was very unique for a woman at the time
mm-hmm
imagine personality Yeah right how dare
she parents so especially in high
society this is rare gossip magazines
being writing about Alice when she was
16 okay she's like Paris Hilton she a
little bit yeah a little bit
in 1899 the vice-president died of a
heart attack and Teddy became vice
president okay Alice moved to Washington
which greatly increased her profile sure
but our behavior at the inauguration in
1901 did not impress Teddy Alice thought
the Roosevelts were superior to the
McKinley's McKinley and she thought
being a VP was quote second place
interesting she referred to President
McKinley as quote a usurping cuckoo Wow
okay so Teddy didn't like that right you
need admonished her a bit on September 6
1901 President McKinley was
by an anarchist
I think we're pro pro I don't know I
don't know what we are anymore he died
eight days later okay so sweet eight
days of suffering sure sure
teddy became president alice rejoiced
that her father was finally taking his
rightful place as president she
described it as quote sheer rapture so
she's not as upset about the shooting as
you would think
no she's excited to get in them like top
spot yeah she's in so now she's like
likes the fact that now she kind of
likes her dad a little bit most likes
that he's the president or pops right
but I mean if your dad becomes the
president then you automate your like
but like if your dad became president
you'd mend fences
uh yeah yeah for sure you would you want
to go to the White House right you want
to try that meatloaf oh yeah see what's
going on there pick up the red phone you
know what I mean Batman get me his
there's no phones huh there's no phones
there's no well there's a thing there's
like you know the Morse pick up the red
Morse system and just type you know be a
TA and Morse yeah yeah whatever they had
like the emergency Morse you know he
[ __ ] hit you're like maybe the bird
do you see the Flintstones mm-hmm okay
so she moves into the White House at 17
years old
that's just great movie plot she
immediately became a celebrity she may
have been the nineteen hundred's first
global celebrity okay
On January 4th 1902 Alice made her debut
to the world so it's her debutante ball
sure she was labeled the White House
debutante okay Teddy kept out of the
limelight that evening Edith handled the
receiving line and presented Alice to
society here is this embarrassing
[ __ ] [ __ ] little [ __ ] whose name
we won't say fifth the best out of five
her name is Thing Thing one everyone
give it up yeah my mom died dude
[Music]
newspapers covered it that it did talked
about her dress the music you know the
whole thing was all described yeah of
course so the media always focused on
the right things always saying a month
later her frame went international when
she christened a yacht that belonged to
Kaiser Wilma when Wilhelm of Germany the
was christened the meteor it would be an
honor if Jill would come down and be
Vonda breaks the champagne upon the
meteor okay
you are the new it girl you know that is
the Kaiser sent his cousin okay
Prince Henry of Prussia to accompany
Alice and shore up relations between
America and Germany sounding very
similar to our situation now would you
know you know about Kaiser Kaiser
Wilhelm is probably the closest thing
that has ever been to Trump I didn't put
the picture in is that the right one
what it's a different one than you were
on before yeah I had to but I had a
picture of Kaiser yeah that's a bummer
all right you can look him up yeah it's
a good photo though they look ridiculous
okay said anyway uh sorry Prince Henry
so he accompanies our short relations to
American Germany Alice broke abolished
champagne over the bow newspapers record
it all including how many times the
Prince touched Alice's arm oh sure right
keep the arm count yeah
um Alice loved the publicity
The Times noted that she seemed above it
all quote she seemed to look upon the
whole affair as a lark so she's kind of
cool
she's it sounds like yeah right it is
like I mean when you play the media like
that you are cool right when you're like
above it whereas most people will be
like oh and she's just like this is
[ __ ] stupid right I mean she thinks
were stupid we love her more right we're
the media so she's grown up not giving a
[ __ ] yeah because of what happened -
yeah and now she's like this is all
[ __ ] dumb
right yeah so she's like cool yeah the
press began speculating that the
president was going to marry off his
daughter to a European monarchy okay The
Tribune quote she has become one of the
most regarded women in the world
replacing the young queen of Holland in
popular favor
okay that's cool that they're ranking
women mhm mhm well we don't do that
anymore though no more it or no list or
whatever yeah so the quote unspoiled
woman was nicknamed Prince Alice by the
papers pretty because she did this thing
with Prince Henry huh and they like hit
it off and shoot them well he touched
her eight times straight to touch her
arm eight times yeah it's pretty hot arm
count and welcome to gossip dish and
then and because he's a prince because
she made a big splash of this thing they
just started calling her princess
princess okay princess Alice and it's
stuck okay immediately after the
christening the owner of the New York
Tribune invited Alice to Edward of the
eighth's coronation in England that's
the hot ticket that's the [ __ ] [ __ ]
right there
who Edward the eight eight eight not
eight eight eight eight eight hey I'm
trying to buy weed his coronation yeah
he's gonna put on the corner oh right
right that's the ceremony and we would
present to you the new man who will be
diagnosing how someone passed he's gonna
come King just like Simba yeah like
Simba now I get it okay
now we're okay now we're getting it so
he sees his pop in the clouds and his
dad sort of emerges from the clouds and
he's like you must keep fighting it
exactly that's how it actually become
combined then [ __ ] scar okay
sorry alright the English insisted on
treating her like she was a princess so
word gets over that she's gonna come and
they are all a flutter about their this
is just exactly how it works
this is like the Megan Merkel story yeah
across the United States people debated
whether or not she should be allowed to
view the coronation with the rest of
English royalty so now they're talking
about if she goes where she will sit
because she's being treated as royalty
so they like well she's is she gonna sit
with the royal family
like what's the bull the media named her
princess especially gotta the monarchy
yeah now she's basically right she's
anointed meanwhile in Europe they were
saying she was deserving of quote the
honors due to the oldest daughter of an
emperor okay so they're all on board in
Europe right but some of the the press
in the u.s. found us all to be unseemly
because of course we are the ones who
fought against the monarchy
yeah we're also named her princess yeah
and we're the ones who elevated her
status your your this is [ __ ]
[ __ ] what you're doing right what
I'm doing is calling out the media again
[ __ ]
so the media accused Alice of having
undemocratic aspirations yeah she wants
to be queen or some [ __ ] Yeah right yeah
how dare she
the Tribune wrote Alice should be
treated as more than a normal American
girl visiting London but not much more
and not as much as royalty and they said
the treatment of the press in America of
the way they were treating her was bad
right quote I have never seen so
brutally wanton and unjustifiable a
series of misrepresentations and
falsehoods about a young girl resorted
to before in the history of newspaper
discussion in this country in an effort
to make a political point
mm-hmm that's gone it was decided she
would not go oh she didn't even go
no thanks over there all the discussion
before she got there look my pathetical
bridges to climb everyone went bug [ __ ]
yeah because she's this huge celebrity
now so as a consolation prize Teddy sent
Alice on a trip to Cuba instead oh well
okay better yeah I would say better
[ __ ] absolutely absolutely better
she's been a month in Havana when she
came back the press followed her every
move
when she drove 45 miles from Newport to
Boston with a friend it made headlines
because they were the only women to make
the trip in a car it's just so weird
yeah it's like it's the fact that two
women and driving in a car is cray well
also we live in a post Elmen louise era
so it's easy for us to look at that now
but it's amazing to think that like two
women driving a car is crazy
and then because she did it it's like oh
my god holy [ __ ] rebel rebel yeah there
were constant reports that she was about
to get married whenever she was seen
with a man none of which were true right
so she's like JFK jr. totally right
historian quote all Edith and Teddy
needed to do to know what Alice had been
up to the night before was to open the
morning paper
so she's just so surely he didn't felt
really cool this is what I wanted so I
was so popular she would often appear on
the front page and legitimate important
news was pushed to the back pages hmm
what what I just I'm sorry I just
sometimes I get caught up in these
comparative mindsets and I just I can't
imagine today the media foregoing actual
important things dialogues that are
pressing say that need to be discussed
immediately Nashville and and letting
that go by the wayside just for
something that's gonna sell the rag yeah
yeah I mean it's just I don't know and I
think that if we had that system today
we would really be [ __ ] yeah things
would really be bad yeah because people
would not be able to get the information
that was valuable instead of having
someone to kind of distill the
importance of what was happening and
explained the nuance we would just kind
of be caught up in what's shiniest and
what's dumbest and what's freshest and
what's most scandalous and I think that
that would probably create a culture
where you know people would find wedge
issues that they would just become
obsessed with and it would kind of drive
a large large chasm between us and the
distance would only spread further and
further the more that we were made to
feel like we didn't have things in
common as much as we had everything to
fight against each other about when in
reality we'd probably agree on 78% of
the [ __ ] I just think it would be weird
oh sorry I was I was thinking about
remember Jay well yeah from Snooki and
JWoww from the yeah yeah I saw a picture
of them today so I was thinking about
that yeah no they are they remain
friends friends and it's pretty cool
untouched by needles yeah I mean that's
yeah so this yeah I just think that kind
of stuff you shouldn't like throw away
you know I mean like that's important
there they stayed friends oh you're
sorry so while you're focusing on you're
focusing on the important news of JWoww
and Snooki I'm I don't know if it's
important I just think it's human yeah I
think there's more important stories to
focus on now you think like the whole
thing with Lady Gaga and Bradley Cooper
like that oh my
like it's kind of a more importance yeah
yeah you know like everything that
happened there like you know sure
there's a lot of issues and stuff but I
just think the chemistry between them
and for them to have that performance in
front of Bradley's girlfriend or fiance
I'm not sure which is but I think that's
what we should be talking about for a
week yeah yeah
by the way ocean life down 4% our
president hugged a flag yep how long
until he inserts himself into it in
front of people and they're like better
better but Alice enjoyed all this
attention she started phoning in tips
about herself too and was paid cash for
it she is the first savvy yeah like
she's the first using the media to her
advantage honey I don't know that's
right
Alice smoked publicly which was not
highly thought of for a young lady at
the time that's disgusting Teddy forbid
her from smoking in the White House and
she responded by going up to the roof
and smoking there better better better
so much better yeah that's a Willie
Nelson teddy wrote a letter to Ted jr.
quote sister yeah sister
I'm sticking with it says it's sister he
is now 17 this Christmas I'm gonna get
you a name and he's good sister
continues to lead the line aimed a star
after you it's Sister Sister continues
to lead the life of social excitement
which is I think all right for a girl to
lead for a year - but which upon my word
I do not regard as healthy from the
standpoint of permanence I wish she had
some pronounced serious taste he noted
she had a habit of dancing all night and
then not getting up until well past noon
cuz should you be more jealous she's 70
Ellis she's doing what she's supposed to
Ellis in 1903 Alice went to Puerto Rico
for Mardi Gras dude this is just when
she left a hundred people including
policeman detectives and Secret Service
men were on the pier to see her off
detectives yeah I know right a little
bit of a creepy send-off
goodbye Alison we'll all be waiting for
when you come back I got Hank ok bye NAT
stick make the boat move mace I'm gonna
duck down myself for being a bad girl on
the island the Tribune wrote quote her
stay in San Juan was a continual aura
nation and her trip across the island
was like a royal progress that's like
when Trump went there it must be
processed that must may be whatever
could be progress yeah so she is
wherever she goes she's being treated
like a princess right her behavior in
Puerto Rico please teddy and when she
returned he gave in to her pleas and
bought her a car okay and you can smoke
in your room
she got a long red touring car and
immediately began racing it down the
streets of DC and getting tickets okay
yeah but the cops are like oh sorry I
didn't realize it was you just going 100
the German naval yacht the Alice
Roosevelt was completed in the crew
asked did I say that they were no I'll
get that oh so so the the German Navy
has the same name Wilhelm was so excited
by her christening but just how popular
she was that he decided to name a German
German Navy yacht Alice Roosevelt is
very specific so the algebra is Teddy
called it sister boats so that's been
built and then the crew asked her for a
picture which she provided so they could
keep on needs to do to get a naval boat
named after her send a picture though
she likes us boys she likes us I mean
she's hot I mean she likes his boys I
think we have a shot she looks like yeah
it's again it's a little hard to tell
because there's so much stuff going on
the head I mean look how high up the
collar finger the whole thing is nuts
it's just like it really is it looks
like your clothes were eating you yeah
like it looks like a snake is halfway
through devouring you but you had to
wear it
and the hats are just okay so basically
you had to wear a cake on your head then
just be swallowed by your dress that's
right so Alice now started riding in
cars with men without chaperones you
can't do that don't she's with vagina oh
dear oh no so this is completely unheard
of also we're ending the the Victorian
area area as ending so like women are
like that's [ __ ] up can I be more of a
person right so she also wore pants
which we've learned on not unacceptable
behavior she chewed gum oh my god not
while wearing pants I'm assuming because
the two combined my lord
she played poker no this is all very
shocking to the public yeah but young
women are in thrall of course young
women were like this is the [ __ ] wow
you have an out you have a trailblazer
everybody in the country knew about her
large and expensive wardrobe when Teddy
took her car away for speeding Alice
would just borrow her friend Marguerite
Cassini's car okay Marguerite is a rich
Russian do you have a dark picture no
yes
okay she's Russian she was an
illegitimate child but then
the guy father made a deal with the so
state that's actually why they connected
a little yeah they had like a real
prison we were born into and let's have
a little fun that's right their
background is kind of similar so she's
also a party girl
Eleanor Roosevelt was a was Alice's
cousin okay not get along at all okay
she told her fiance FDR that Alice was
quote looking well but crazier than ever
I saw her this morning of combi I saw
her this morning in Bobby galazy Auto
quite along with three other men uh-huh
so that's bad to be in a car with four
dudes
yo Alice drank gin she went and watched
the Wright brothers make their trial
flights in her purse she kept a dagger
and a copy of the Constitution so she's
a little that's allowed Jonesy yeah
certainly
my dad does Jeffries does whatever
rumors began that Alice was going to the
racetrack often but the family was
suppressing the pictures her life is
Dinah awesome she's [ __ ] she don't
want a permanent vacation that's right
so all this is going on Teddy was in New
York on business so she was sent to New
York to get a lecture from Teddy about
getting your [ __ ] together
right but I've decided to be a father a
good time you need to get your act
together now I would call you by your
knees and baby look you don't have one
I'm so mad I'm gonna call you by your
full name princess baby Lee mousey kins
um apparently it didn't take coz when
she got back a headline announced she
been seen at the track quote she is as
much an attraction as the thoroughbreds
her family a family Fred said she was
quote like a young wild animal that has
been put into Teddy Mike killer we're
not careful like a young wild animal
that has been put into good clothes
okay okay so she's a Teen Wolf there
she's in the car those hands look at the
nightmare life you have with how are you
driving a car with those Hatter neck by
the end of the day like oh my god I mean
it's just crazy yeah and it looks
ridiculous a little bird on it get an
owl on there you weirdos other person
Maine 1904 she went to the Louisiana
Purchase exposition where she was met by
a cheering crowd of thousands people
wanted to catch a glimpse of the
princess so badly that they almost
crushed her against her carriage that's
that's about to Lenny would the bunny's
her I love her so much that we're gonna
crush her up against the wall now our
men on board with this are they
threatened as I would imagine them to be
I would imagine men are threatened this
is mostly young girls right she's she's
breaking the [ __ ] mole yeah she is
she's a big deal right yeah she's a big
[ __ ] deal right quote language by the
New York Times quote miss Roosevelt
found herself in the presence of a crowd
of 5,000 chiefly women also all
shrieking there she is and hurrah for
Miss Roosevelt bring back her ah yeah
also I want that's what I want people to
yeah I I'm gonna start doing three
cheers in rooms now two three cheers
imagine being at a time when you said
three cheers for stuff Oh God three
cheers for David hip-hip as mr.
Roosevelt's party reached their courage
the women burst the ineffective police
Barry and a flood of femininity swirled
about the carriage they were all trying
to peer peer over each other's heads and
most of them were harrowing yeah well
what the Hat it must have been really
hard to see past each other
hurrah hurrah hurrah did you hear my her
are previously only great women of the
theater
had brought out such crowds a
high-society teen getting this treatment
was completely unheard of but alice is
breaking the model for young women
Alice postcards became big sellers so so
postcards all over the place of her
right and that's a big deal back then I
guess so I'm sure it's gotta be right to
be it had to be in some pockets of my
family postcards are still a big deal
so posed I mean think about that like
when I was a kid like people would buy
postcards and it would be like yeah and
as the people it's raining I used to do
that yeah I think then it was probably
like this Oh crazy yeah there is a with
a picture on it oh my god it it's a
valise oh yes
we live in the future ah so young women
wanted clothes of Alice's favorite color
which was a gray blue which became known
as Alice blue millions of American girls
all on the cusp of the new woman
movement emulated everything she said
and did okay
songs were written about her like Alice
blue gown and Alice where art thou if
babies were named after her like a maid
never called sister yeah this is baby
baby Lea this is baby baby Lea so Alice
kept doing her thing she fired off cap
guns at parties she danced a midnight
hoochie coochie on the Vanderbilts roof
what does that even mean
I don't know what the hoochie coochie is
Aaron can you do it she drove her own
car and now had her own pet snake
well hello which she brought to social
function what there's no picture of the
snob oh [ __ ] here he is oh god this that
what's his name again this is Prince
Henry Prince Henry
he looks so stiff so what else do you
like to do for fun
that's cool that's cool I'll try to put
these up on Instagram that's cool so she
has a pet snake which she would bring
everywhere into social functions yes
like white houses really now becoming
this is taking a turn I mean she is
fully like she's lucky she's really
trying like she's like what will it take
for people to stop me I think I'm too
powerful like she's just like I'm gonna
blow all this I bring cobras to parties
all right I'm driving a car with five
guys in it and I'm bringing a snake with
me so yeah so she has a snake the pet
snake was named Emily spinach she named
it that because quote it says green is
spinach and as thin as my Aunt Emily oh
nice
Emily spinach was a garter snake and
when it ate an egg it had a hump no
that's the different wears a lot of
cases that's its Anna Anna Bob so it's a
so it's a garter snake and she would
carry it around in her pocket or
sometimes around her neck or it said
pocketbook but I I don't think they had
purses I don't know but whatever and I
would have pocketbooks
it's a pocketbook a purse but they never
have when the pictures they never have a
purse with them
well they put it down Dave I feel like
they wouldn't be a lot I think they're
like they would think it was wrong for
them to carry purses at this time I
might be totally I think you're lying it
probably did but they needed two pockets
were went when pockets were invented
amazing to think that pockets were
invented for women and it made a huge
difference in their lives pocket pockets
was one of those weird revolutionary
things for women right it's insane right
because they weren't they couldn't they
weren't allowed to carry anything and
also in the head my god what a
convenience Jesus Christ you're lucky I
let you outside
Alice hid Emily spinach in covered
dinner plates during White House
banquets and would wait for guests to
freak out when they remove the cover
okay so Billy Madison is in the way okay
so she also like to barge into meetings
in the White House with no purpose other
than to [ __ ] with everyone there okay
and then she'd start giving advice sure
she would go so she would go into
official meetings and start giving
advice and tell you like get the [ __ ]
out of here I think you should clean up
your language Oh what's her name that's
girl yeah yeah
after there your posture is garbage
leave the Oval Office Alice he smokes
too much get out
after she interrupted one meeting three
times Teddy threatened to throw her out
a window I'll throw you out a window my
loveseat seems like he would too ya know
he seems pretty chill this is what's
best for you I'll do it you'll thank me
later
so yeah it's we all know what Teddy
looks like that's yeah that's her ma'am
yeah the guy who looks like he's wearing
two monocles he does doesn't yeah cuz he
because he's got it's it's a monocle
thing but it's it's too good yeah that
just seems like a be super terrible
really and conveying your little weird
glasses all the time yeah Alice then
began saying she was a pagan which was
probably just a way to upset the very
religious yeah she started calling
Christianity voodoo I'm waiting for her
to do something I'm not into does teddy
was furious he accused Alice of quote
courting publicity which was not
something a lady did no lady does not
court polluted he wrote that she
described
oh sorry hello it's my bad he wrote he
wrote a letter that she described as
savage okay
and it was telling her to - you know get
a [ __ ] together right
Alice burned the letter so we don't know
what it was but there's one telegram
that survived about her serving tea to
charity function okay from Teddy quote
do not like the advertisements of your
appearing at a portrait show they
distinctly convey the impression that
any person who wishes to pay five
dollars may be served with tea by you
and Ethel Barrymore
I cannot consent to such a use of your
name and must ask you not to serve tea
tea is just that as wit's end it's a
[ __ ] game he can just go serving tea
for five bucks send a telegram eyelid
monitor via telegram Alice responded
that she got the telegram too late
[Music]
now there's another layer to this which
is teddy is Teddy Roosevelt he wants to
be the center of attention yeah so she's
taking away his jam right right
at one point Alice said her dad quote he
wants to be the bride and every wedding
at the corpse at every funeral and the
baby in every Christmas oh man
so that's calling someone a narcissist
yeah yeah she's I gotta tell you she's a
very attractive devar you look no but
you know no love but that's a
good-looking lady
there's no hat no hat there but she's
got a bunch of BS on her back of her
head she's got a flower mullet yeah
she's gonna carry that so so Alice hung
out with a group of sorts hanging about
the group of other daughters who are
super rich here we go
grace Vanderbilt [ __ ] patters the first
daughter's Club yeah Wow and Marguerite
who we already met so this just
increases attention with with Teddy and
Edith okay as a group they were worse so
when the girls get together because the
Super Friends they were all encouraging
each other right there's more power and
rules they openly flirted with men they
made trips to New York Newport in
Washington the social circles they went
to each other's parties they encouraged
each other to push the bounds of social
norms okay they would they would also
bail on parties like people would throw
them like a hundred thousand dollar
party and they would just bail on it
like they were just right yeah living it
living it Marguerite said she and Alice
were quote too badly spoiled girls set
only on their own pleasure right New
York the New York Herald printed a tally
of Alice's social life okay 407 dinners
350 balls 300 parties 680 tees 1706
social calls in 15 months Wow that is I
don't I think you're eating multiple
dinners I mean
it's a 407 dinner's in 15 months by the
way a baller days I'm balling a party
very similar yeah no your and there's
separate categories yeah you're hitting
two of these things or three of these
things in a day yeah I mean this whole
time party John 1706 so she calls in 15
months yeah yeah it's a lot
the girls were rarely home except to
change clothes or sleep Teddy needeth
became more and more upset as time went
by and Teddy was convinced they were
squandering their lives on frivolous
pursuits and demoralizing pleasures
which is what they should be doing
they're like eighteen more you knew that
you girls could have fun it should be
before Cyndi Lauper broke the mold I
mean it should all be demoralizing
pleasure that's that's what you should
everyone should be doing yeah if you
wink at me again Norma's episode I will
leave you get the camera on me people
are listening to this there it's a wink
for the people at home Teddy to a friend
quote I can do one of two things I can
be president or I can control Alice I
cannot do both that is I mean you're the
president your job is to put out all the
fires and just sort of have an echelon
of these issues you have to deal with I
mean you need to deal with 85 different
problems your whole job is putting fires
out and he's like I can't be the
president and be the father of this girl
this virus too big and he's [ __ ]
Teddy Roosevelt Yeah right so this is
like for him it's like interesting to
hear an Achilles heel
he considered Alice's pursuit of
publicity to be quote vulgar I'd get
that's what it's cuz she that's what he
does like she's literally marrying him
actually he's being think about it she
is being the bride at every wedding the
corpse of every few and the baby at
every Christmas
well it's cuz she's a woman that it's
vulgar but it's everything he does sure
but things began to change in 1904 maybe
it was the wise but poverty that was
hitting America but her her actions
start to look a little worse because of
what's happening in the country right
maybe it was the fact that was she's
clearly disobeying her father
either way the sunpapers started to be
more critical of her actions
one such paper was called town topics
which was about the rich but the rich
tried to stay out of the paper so it's
like the scandals bad [ __ ] you know town
topics turned on Alice and her friends
the paper was run by a formal several
the paper was run by a former civil war
colonel who let the wealthy purchase
immunity from negative stories so you
can buy yeah there's not any like
version of that today no no what do you
think like there's not a like a specific
like media publication like a
publication that if there was bad news
about you could buy a rich person or buy
their way out of Canada a presidential
candidate you could buy that information
yeah okay yeah so so that didn't happen
for Alice the paper wrote quote from
wearing costly lingerie to indulging in
fancy dances for the edification of men
it was only a step however it is
admitted that she is a smart girl and
smart girls are supposed to be clever
enough to take care of themselves
without the aid of chaperones yeah
he also said she was using stimulants
and had listened to some risque jokes
told by the son of a Newport hostess
well so she heard some dirty joke yeah
that's a problem yeah he heard she sat
there and listened to dirty jokes the
guy who told the joke when a woman is
supposed to be like Oh fainting couch
animated fall down that's fine yeah
right but the female faint her ears need
to be cut off that's right thank you the
owner of call your weekly a magazine had
previously been attacked by tan topics
and saw this as a chance to attack back
so he's not he doesn't have to he's like
it's great for him because this is a
popular girl and he can he can defend
her honor and
he also refused to believe Alice's high
jinks would include such list Sevilla
Cydia sness
so he doesn't think that she would be
off with man or listing also not right I
mean do you think she's like how far do
we think she's gone with dudes I don't
know but whatever it's like you should
like if you you know it's just amazing
it's there still is this double standard
where like if a you know like a dude
sleeps with a bunch of girls oh yeah
yeah get all ready champ and a girl
sleeps with a bunch of guys just like
man what's wrong with you horrible
horrible act you've committed but I'm
wondering if like if like like what
happens to her if she has sex like well
I was I don't know what that I don't
know what the air is like and what
happened I was thinking like when you
said she flirts like the first time that
a girl flirted with a gentleman it must
have been like what is happening yeah
this is the total opposite of everything
I've ever been taught maybe but I think
they flirted all the time but I think
you flirted with a chaperone around I
don't know what I don't [ __ ] get a
little [ __ ] it's so restrictive and an
anti humanity that it doesn't like it so
alien yeah so call your fires back the
two papers fought back and forth in
editorials and the editor of Colliers
sued town topic for blackmail and time
topics sued for libel the case was
really a battle between old Victorian
morals and what was replacing them but
it put Alice's life in even more on
display okay so Teddy decided send Alice
on a long cruise to Asia in 1905 okay
hehehe on one hand he wanted her to get
away from her friends right and on the
other he thought seeing developing
nations would be good for her right so
seeing right seeing people Philippines
or whatever people do do not have it the
right we have it yes this is a boat Hail
Mary but she was also sent as a
distraction for the press so he knew
that the press would be focused on her
because her presence would allow war
secretary Secretary William Taft who was
her chaperone Taft was her chaperone
tapped as a chaperone on this trip talk
about an easy chaperone to ditch it's
Taft II know that's so weird because he
has this reputation that I've certainly
played into that he's extremely obese
yeah he doesn't look obese there it is
no looks like a linebacker yeah are you
thinking of someone else
no tat wasn't half the huge one I don't
remember is it yeah he was gonna get
stuck in a bathtub yeah well he's not
big there no I'll show you know that
picture he's bigger okay so so so Taft
is her chaperone but he's also the war
secretary because he's actually there to
conduct secret negotiations with Japan
so they're using her as what do you call
it a decoy yeah she's the decoy like
she's gonna distract distract all the
press right and he's gonna get this
business done okay
so along on the tried a mission that
Roosevelt has created for that's right
the - and talk about a movie yeah I
don't know where she is
there's also 23 congressmen and seven
senators on the trip Jesus it was called
the Imperial cruise and it was the first
time the daughter of a president had
been a goodwill ambassador people in the
countries they visited all referred to
her as Princess Alice okay her
reputation was only increased by going
on the trip so Alice understood the
protocol and she worked within the
limits on the trip though she's still
Alice right so the trip starts she takes
a train to San Francisco on the train
trip she pulled out a pistol and took
shots at targets on the top of telephone
poles as the train passed what this is
quite this is in America stuff yes
America okay so she's shooting it
whatsoever is on the top of telephone
poles sure but really wires yet wires
that are important to people's
communication for sure
she also one day set off firecrackers in
the Train
and when people said what the [ __ ] you
doing she said it's the fourth of July
and it wasn't I don't know if it wasn't
probably and still even if it was that's
not a valid excuse for firecracker
hearing a train what you got a San
Francisco she slipped her chaperone and
spent the night all alone in China - I
can't find Alice come on she had him
don't help you oh well great
Taft to have tried to find her I find
Alice something on a ship they went to
Hawaii where she danced the hula and
then she put on a bathing suit and went
surfing and Taft begged the
photographers not to take her picture
so Taft this is pretty early in the trim
tab this resorting to pleaded pleading
with them please stop yeah she jumped
fully clad so you stopped the media
normally that's right yeah that doesn't
make them more excited back then they
were probably like all right sorry
William she jumped fully clothed into
the ship's swimming pool no no no lunacy
all she had on was a linen top and a
linen skirt so so potentially I mean I'm
sure she had women were lucky enough to
wear 16 layers of clothes they probably
had to get like something to rip her out
of the water
Alice said it was her quote pleasurable
duty to stir up her fellow travelers
from time to time nice
so in each country she was given tons of
expensive gifts the press started
calling the government-sponsored trip
Alice in plunder land oh there we go
finally finally a hero in the media
emerges but she okay there's big boy
Taft right there we got expanded yeah
but a poet actually came up with that
title and then the press ran was right
in the Chinese imperial guard she's only
wearing the two dresses there right yeah
look at that
v1 and then the other one and then D
Pizza hat in the Chinese imperial
gardens she was carried on the shoulders
of four Chinese men the country's all
thought if they wanted to gain good well
in the trip they would have to treat
Alice very well one traveler on the trip
wrote in his diary quote perhaps to most
alice was the party this was so outside
as well as inside the country before the
trip during the trip and after the trip
many times after I returned the only
question that was asked of me of the
experiences of Asia was how did you like
Alice right did you see all the sights I
mean Alice so she did she spread
goodwill wherever she went
everybody loved her all the Asian
countries were like yeah she's great
from Tokyo to Manila when they reach
Korea headlines and US papers just said
quote Seoul welcomes her they didn't
even say who she was everyone just knew
her was Alice right but this it did the
plan by this account would be working
then essentially right because the plan
is to send sort of Taft and these other
people all over the place to do some
secret [ __ ] yes and then but she just is
clearly in the limelight so yeah so when
she was in Korea
Alice scandalously walked arm-in-arm and
flirted with Ohio congressman Nick
Longworth okay Longworth was 15 years
older so trapped trapped so Taft tried
to do everything he could to keep them
apart
but Taft eventually gave up because he
could not control Alice he then asked a
left Alice he then asked Alice if she
was in love with Longworth and Alice
said quote more or less mr. secretary
more or less Longworth was a notorious
DC playboy womanizer and you'll see why
oh my god this man he he was a boozer
he was short he was balding but he was
wealthy in horizon political star she
was yeah daddy issues
oh but 150 percent daddy issues
yeah I'd look at the collar it's great
oh this is not the man I thought but
this is what happens you know
Joe DiMaggio ended up with Marilyn
Monroe yeah but he's the great baseball
player and still has no excuse maybe one
of the best ever it's not okay Oh
consecutive hits Dave keep trying what
you can tell me that he you know
joltin Joe joltin Joe is getting you
nowhere with me on a palm return that
was a war crime upon returning Alice
decided to try to beat the japanned to
New York travel time record what is she
doing she just like she I mean if there
was social media back then holy [ __ ]
Teddy was angry when he heard he was
worried about her saying I wanna take
the regular route regular train not fast
he was where you want to safety on a
speeding train I was offended she'd
accepted a ride from another rich guy eh
Harriman he sent word for Harriman to
slow down the train which he did but it
didn't matter
Harriman had done it for the publicity
and it worked people lined the train
tracks to watch the train pass by waving
American flags and bands plate like I
know but it's like it's a teenage girl
on a derail you pine for the days when
that was stimulating I do I think we I
think our brains probably our brains on
a bomb where to focus on when you're big
week event was going to watch a train
and then it's gone and then
go read yeah all right I agree so Alice
got off in New York after the trip she
was at the height of her popularity
right so she's coming back she's
basically like she's an American Hero
because she's done all this great stuff
sure yeah she did all that stuff the
Richmond times-dispatch called her quote
an American girl who has not been
spoiled she had served the interests of
America well overseas and everyone loved
her for it and has she not been spoiled
I think spoiled meaning a different kind
of boy okay and now she was hanging out
with Congressman Longworth you mean the
sex symbol we saw earlier yeah the hot
pot dude he was seen she was seen
driving with him without a chaperone the
Tribune wrote wrote quote if they are
not engaged they ought to be so the
Tribune kept following them and then a
day before the family was going to
announce they're engaged the Tribune
broke the story first they're engaged
Teddy supports it because Longworth had
graduated from Harvard he's also gonna
be good good a constant chaperone
yes please you try you try
I was about to resign so he's into it
cuz Longworth graduated from Harvard and
was a good family from a good family and
a Roosevelt supporter the try the
trifecta for a son for any politician
the press went insane in the Rob to the
wedding the couple could barely walk
down New York streets because they were
surrounded by crowds the wedding was
piqued Princess Alice madness it was at
the White House in February 1906
so the wedding happens they're cutting
the cake she gets so irritated by the
knife that they're using to cut the cake
that she turns around and takes a
military aid sword quote brandished it
aloft and began slashing the cake with
it the slices fell right and left
and great was the scramble among her
friends well I I support her but this is
someone who has not heard no a lot okay
if you are
Kitana Inge a wedding cake at the White
House you're in charge okay I don't care
who they say is the president if there's
a cake and you take a sword off the
soldier and you start to hack it yeah
and nobody stops you nobody's worried or
stopped you or nobody has the guts to
stop you you're the new president you
are in charge hundred percent I don't
like this old bread knife yeah who wants
cake
just they received extravagant wedding
gifts including fine perfumes from the
Empress of China a twenty-five thousand
dollar tapestry from the president of
France a Florentine mosaic $25,000
tapestry yeah is it made from money I
don't know it's from it's from France I
think they're I think they're inflating
the price two bosses from a former
president of France antique jewelry from
the king of Spain and a pearl necklace
worth $25,000 from the people of Cuba
okay Alice in was insistent on calling
it her loot loot however yeah I mean no
I love her who will say no to her she's
gonna use the sword yeah but after the
wedding a couple days over the wedding
Edith said to Alice quote here we go
I want you to know I'm glad to see you
leave you have never been anything but
trouble yeah well I mean whatever I know
you are in like an 18th tier character
in the story you ain't [ __ ] Edith still
Alice was free of Edith so she must have
been happy
the couple were not really in love as
much as they were comfortable with each
other and Nick was a chronic adulterer
so he went about his [ __ ]
that guy is it's just there's he and so
Alice did too okay she started having
affairs with men on the side after the
honeymoon great yeah after the honeymoon
Alice generally out of the spotlight
okay in 1909 Teddy's presidency ended
before they left the White House Alice
went and buried a voodoo doll in the
White House lawn the voodoo doll was of
the new first lady Helen Taft what's
going on nothing just a little gift for
the future administration all right not
a doll hmm so people found it she must
have told people because people well you
can't keep a secret like that
I mean I can you didn't well tonight so
sorry
so anyway they found out about it and
she all sized the taff's and so Alice
was banned from the White House was her
beef purely the chaperoned experience
with Taft or she just is I really
couldn't find out a lot of the stuff you
try to read about her it just gets vague
so well I mean also they probably
weren't focused but she politics she
clearly did not like his wife because
she did bury a voodoo doll and and right
I forgot about that
right she buried right when Woodrow
Wilson beat her father in the next
presidential election she publicly
talked [ __ ] about him okay once again
she was banned from the White House okay
she also one of the reasons she was
banned from the White House was because
she told a quote unprintable joke about
Woodrow Wilson
I could not find it anywhere it like
doesn't exist it does not you cannot
find it you no one knows what damn it
Teddy Roosevelt died on January 6 1919
he had been against the u.s. joining the
League of Nations so Alice took up the
cause when Wilson pushed for it and she
was so effective using all of her
connections that she was nicknamed the
colonel of death well she did bury a
voodoo doll in a lawn and the u.s. did
not join Wow
so she beat Wilson I mean people can't
say it was definitely her but she
clearly had an influence on what
happened yeah she had the media she
became such a fixture in Washington DC
that she became known as the other
Washington Monument there's a lot of
nicknames so in the 1920s Alice started
having an affair with Senator William
Bora Bora Bora Bo there he is
no just click the image so he's a
good-looking dude yeah so she definitely
likes older dudes this dude is like yeah
she's pretty into the older that did it
oh man he's the chair of the Senate
Foreign Relations Committee so he's kind
of a moving sexual
never again they fell in love they wrote
letters to each other he's still married
to dude right he's still married okay
but that dudes a womanizer - yeah yeah
but I'm just curious their affair became
known the press started calling her
Aurora Borealis the press they still
have it so so in 1925 Alice's husband
Nick became Speaker of the House and
they had a child okay
Paulina I would I was just gonna say
it's time to get a family involved in
this now look at the happy family Jesus
um Nick loved his daughter even though
she was clearly Senator Boris oh that
explains the vibe odds are Nick knew
that Nick died in 1931 he did not leave
much money behind to make money Alice
published her memoirs and during the
Depression Alice wrote a newspaper
column and appeared in a cigarette ad oh
nice Oh Alice Roosevelt Longworth says
there a light smoke kind to the throat
what does this quote say can you make it
a little bigger I can't kind to the
throat that's what I always wonder like
did did people feel like because even if
you didn't think cigarettes were gonna
kill you did your throat get sore yeah
what I mean you were just like well it's
it's normal it happens so Alice was not
a great mother what was that dude - I
mean I can't imagine why do you think
it's because she's not a great mom she
never tried to keep the the secret of
the real father and so she like she's a
total smartass and she's got a great wit
you know she's really [ __ ] funny and
she got away with the words but she
didn't have like
the thing that you would consider you
killas like a yes something's missing
and so Sochi if people are like yeah
that's not Nixon and she's like that's
right like she just did right so at one
point she openly mocked the situation
and said she considered naming her
daughter Deborah because the center's
name is bull right so life went on she
hated the hearings on me on American
Activities Committee Senate committee at
one point McCarthy Joseph McCarthy
called her Alice and she said quote no
Senator McCarthy you are not going to
call me Alice the truck men the trash
man and the policemen on the block may
call me Alice but you may not Wow
her daughter Pauline I don't know why
struggle with depression and addiction
she overdosed on sleeping pills in 1957
the Washington Post said it was suicide
but Alice got them to print a retraction
so then Alice got custody of her
granddaughter Pauline had a kid and this
time she doted over her and cared for
her and a mulligan
yeah Mulligan and she and she loved the
kid and did a good job with the kid
she's always a fixture in Washington she
voted Republican she was super you know
she's [ __ ] rich so she was she was as
awesome as she was for I think what she
did for women she's still a really rich
person who hated FDR and he was doing
him she ended up voting for the Kennedys
though cuz she it was the first
Democrats she loved who just happened to
be from her crazy rich she even voted
for LBJ but then she became a Nixon
supporter after Bobby was killed it's
quite a turnaround yeah but she but
she's a Republican yeah she was just the
key legs but to go from Bobby back to
Nixon that's quite a move throughout
most of her life she preferred to be
called mrs. L rather than Alice okay
after a lifetime of smoking cigarettes
and a double mastectomy due to breast
cancer in her 80s Alice died on February
20th 1988
birthday yeah so there to be 96 yeah Wow
damn so she's uh she's [ __ ] about it
yeah yeah I mean the idea though if you
if you're driving Teddy Roosevelt insane
yourself yeah well I mean they you know
they totally manufactured a person who
was not going to give a [ __ ] right they
the way that they way her childhood went
like I just can't you know it it would
be amazing today if you thought about
someone getting like a younger like
woman getting involved in mainstream
political [ __ ] and all the established
old people thinking like this is too
much this person is too crazy this is
not how we do things but in reality it's
the person who can use the media way
better than you and actually is
effective yeah
there's nobody like that that
establishment politicians hate now and
they're really worried because it's
someone who's actually a real person
it's not full of [ __ ] but yeah I mean
there is like it also shows you first of
all how stupid the media is but also how
you can manipulate it properly at times
and really just again how dumb the
system that white men set up is flawed
and ridiculous and just you just got to
punch holes through it treat the system
like that [ __ ] Plinko game on The
Price is Right punch some goddamn holes
in it thank you got a punch holes to get
they sound little Plinko chips out
really how much the price is right a
couple yeah you got a you just got a
[ __ ] kick doors in and do it you're
gonna do you can't sit on a wait for the
establishment [ __ ] heads to they're
never going to they're never gonna
change your mind so you have to kick
doors down yeah and like so let's say
you're in Nashville and you're a hotel
enjoying this hotel recycle and they're
like no and you're like this hotel
literally doesn't recycle and then you
walk for blocks looking behind
buildings everywhere - just find one
place to put some recycling but that
means that they don't do it honest well
then when I asked people they were like
oh yeah not here not here like you think
I think when I think about all this
stuff we think about and talk about all
the time you're like our I mean all the
stuff our minds are really devoted to is
that [ __ ] give a [ __ ] and then you're
like but they don't even try a little
hell of a town though well good good
he's a good egg I like her yes I'm in
what I like her I'm in I'm in yes what
all right you know what whatever I'm
done I'm out of here don't take this
hello what are you doing I'm on the
phone with Hollywood yeah all right yeah
let's do the deal
yeah no I'm you winning I'm putting some
stupid right now with an [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] is wrong when we start shooting
next Monday love it shooting what how do
I have a friend who claims he has boobs
to be in the movie
no I don't you're the worst fake phone
call pretender taker that I've ever met
well you're the worst coming up with
neighbors for things that just happened
Geyer i've ever met her I killed it
thanks Aaron it's been a lot of fun
[Music]
anyway the ladies are doing it for
themselves
my dog weighs 200 pounds